Osaka is on high alert over 32,000
police officers have come to the venue
of the g20 summit from all over the
country and many main traffic routes
into the city are in lockdown all public
school students have two days off and
residents are asked to refrain from
using cars and going out if not
necessary in the major stations coin
lockers and garbage bins are sealed off
to counter terrorist attacks and
security is ramped up at key locations
close to where the heads of state will
be staying I'm from Osaka and I really
hope that everything goes down safely
I'm proud to have the g20 summit here
the sirens are a bit much I have a young
child my baby hasn't been able to take a
proper nap in a while usually bustling
attractions like parts of Osaka Castle
Park and the inside of the castle are
closed off to the public since part of
the summit is to be held inside the
grounds contrary to the g20 summits held
in Argentina and Germany in the last
years they haven't been any major
protests here in Osaka I've talked to
organizers of a protest on Sunday and
they estimated that only about 200
people came and that's compared to
thousands in Argentina last year and
tens of thousands in Hamburg in Germany
in 2017 overall the city is expecting
30,000 visitors over the course of the
weekend all right I am joined now by GW
correspondent max Hoffman who is in
Osaka Japan covering the summit there
max a lot of ground to be covered by the
world leaders there what can we expect
from this summit indeed a lot of ground
to be covered and traditionally you know
these g20 summits are about promoting
multilateral trade and the main
instrument to do that is a declaration
that the leaders need to accept at the
end and that is prepared by so called
Sherpas they've been doing that now
since Sunday here in Osaka and we're
hearing things aren't going too well
although the Japanese presidency is
really trying to put the focus on those
topics that are afterwards in the
declaration there are so many important
topics on the sidelines just take Iran
for example or the well the Chinese
American trade conflict that the
Japanese presidency indeed is afraid
that all the attention will be steered
away from from their focus and maybe
that in the end there won't even be a
declaration on the table at least the
last g20 summits for example in Buenos
Aires at the end of last year have
always been extremely difficult because
of that all right well let's talk about
President Trump of course all eyes on
him during g20 summits like the one in
Osaka right now he's often been at odds
with other leaders who were there is
there a sense that he will dominate this
summit as well well so far he's already
tweeted you know a couple of things that
are worrisome for some of the countries
hit the bottom line of what he's always
saying it's always been the same message
really is that America is being treated
unfairly by its trade partners and the
latest victim of one of the tweets here
was was India but also Germany is also
mentioned in these and the g20 summits
where I have been with Donald Trump
indeed he's always managed to overshadow
this this hard work which is you know
not as not as offensive maybe to some as
what Trump does in his tweets so there's
a real danger here that the same thing
will happen especially because you have
the two biggest economies in the world
the United States of America and China
teetering on the edge of a full-blown
trade war all right and I just have a 20
seconds left a Maxo what are the chances
that the Chinese and American leaders
will overcome their differences during
this g20 summit in Osaka they'll have a
bilateral meeting on Saturday President
Xi of China President Trump of the
United States some
said we've had media reports that Trump
is ready to have a truce there and back
off of additional tariffs that he wanted
to slap on Chinese goods but you can
never be really be sure just take the
last summative born as I Reese after
that he was very positive so he said
China and the US would work out a deal
but then really exactly the opposite
happened so in this case it's really not
the words that count but the work that's
done afterwards and the actual agreement
that might or maybe not be negotiated
max Hoffman reporting from Osaka thank
you